the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
as you all know hbo is working on
another series that's set in george r
martin's the song of ice and fire
universe house of the dragon will begin
filming very soon
and as long as they stay on schedule the
first season will be released in a
little over a year from now
since george r martin has created such
an amazing story
that also has a very large fan base hbo
knows they have a lot of different
options when it comes to developing
shows based on his books
long before game of thrones ended they
had five different writers creating five
different shows
now if that wasn't exciting enough it
was just recently
announced that hbo also wants to make a
series based on the adventures of dunkin
egg
as well as robert's rebellion it's
obvious hbo doesn't want to leave
westeros just yet
so i decided i would make a few videos
about some of the events surrounding
robert's rebellion
since there is a good chance we could
see this get brought to life
i know some of you still haven't read
any of the books so i will show you what
it says
just to give you an idea about what
caused the rebellion as well as what
happened during it
and shortly after in my last video i
went over some things that happened at
harrenhal because i think that one event
could make up for most of the first
season of the show
not only that but there were also a few
things that happened at harrenhal that
shaped what would happen in the future
the one thing everyone remembers is that
was when rhaegar gave lyanna the blue
winter roses
making it very obvious he was interested
some would even argue that was when
lyanna fell in love with rhaegar
now regardless of how they felt about
one another the fact is
they both went missing shortly after
that you could say
this is what sparked robert's rebellion
one of the other very interesting things
that happened at harrenhal was when
jaime lannister became the newest and
youngest sworn brother of the kingsguard
this meant that jaime would spend most
of his days by the mad king's side
this wasn't a very smart move by the mad
king considering he just became
enemies with jaime's father tywin
lannister
as you already know jaime executes the
mad king
as his father is sacking the city but i
don't want to get too far ahead of
myself
just yet let's begin right where i left
off in my last video
rhaegar had just handed lyanna the blue
roses we found out lyanna's brother
brandon was not very happy about this
he even had to be restrained because he
wanted to confront rhaegar
as he saw this as a slight upon his
sister's honor
after all she was already set up to
marry robert baratheon
now as for robert baratheon himself some
say he laughed at rhaegar's gesture
saying he was only given lyanna her due
however
those who knew robert better say the
young lord brooded on the insult
and his heart hardened toward rhaegar
from that day forth
based on what happens shortly after this
i think it's safe to say
robert wasn't very happy about this
either the false spring of 281 ac
only lasted a few years as the final
year came to an end
the winter returned with a vengeance on
the last day of the year
snow began to fall upon king's landing
and a crust of ice
formed atop the blackwater rush the
snowfall fell off and on for the best
part of a fortnight
until the black water was frozen and
icicles hung from the roofs and gutters
of every house in the city
as the cold winds hammered down on
king's landing the mad king aerys was
having his pyromancers drive the winter
off with their magic
enormous green fires burned along the
walls of the red keep for several nights
rhaegar was not in the city to observe
them however nor could he be found in
dragonstone with his wife elia
and their young son aegon with the
coming of the new year
rhaegar had taken to the road with a
half a dozen of his closest friends and
confidants
on a journey that would ultimately lead
him back to the riverlands
not far from harrenhal rhaegar fell upon
lyanna stark of winterfell
and carried her off lighting a fire that
would consume his house
ian kin and all those he loved and half
the realm besides
what followed rhaegar's infamous
abduction of lyanna stark was the ruin
of house targaryen
the full depth of king aerys madness was
subsequently revealed in his depraved
actions against lord stark
his heir and their supporters after they
demanded things were made right for
rhaegar's wrongs
ned's father and brother brandon went to
king's landing looking for rhaegar
lyanna and or justice i'm standing
right here when it happened it was very
brave your brother
your father too i didn't deserve to die
like that
nobody deserves to die like that but you
just stood there and marched
500 men just stood there and watched
all the great nights of the seven
kingdoms you think anyone said a word
lifted a finger
instead of granting them a fair hearing
the mad king heiress had them brutally
slain
then followed those murders by demanding
that lord john aaron
execute his former wards robert
baratheon and eddard stark
many now agree that the start of
robert's rebellion began with lord
aaron's refusal
and his courageous calling of his
banners in defense of justice
this is one of the reasons robert
baratheon made jon aaron his hand
not only because he was like a father
figure to him and ned but also because
he supported them during the rebellion
now although john aaron was loved and
respected
not all the lords of the vale agreed
with his decision
and soon after fighting broke out as
some of the supporters of the crown
attempted to bring lord john aaron down
the fighting then spread across the
seven kingdoms like wildfire
as lords and knights chose their
respective sides
most of the older characters you saw in
game of thrones fought in these battles
robert baratheon proved himself a
fearless indomitable warrior as
more and more men flocked to his banner
robert was the first one over the walls
at gull town
when lord grafton raised his banner for
targaryens
and from there he sailed to storm zen
risking capture by the royal fleet
to call his own banners not all of them
came willing by the way
the mad king aries hand lord
merriweather encouraged certain storm
lords to rise up against robert
baratheon
it was an effort that ended up being
fruitless following robert's victories
at summerhall
where he won three battles in a single
day his hastily gathered forces defeated
lord grandeston
and catherine in turn and robert went on
to kill lord fell in single combat
before taking his famous son
silverax captive more victories were to
come for lord robert baratheon and the
stormlords as they marched to join
forces with jon arryn
and the northmen who supported their
cause rightly famed and robert's grand
victory at stoney sept
also called the battle of the bells
where he slew the famous sir miles
mooton
who was once rhaegar squire and five men
besides
and might well have killed the new hand
lord connington
had the battle brought them together so
as you can see
robert is like a wrecking ball knocking
over everything in his sight
the victory sealed the entry of the
riverlands into the conflict
following the marriage of lord talley's
daughters to lords john aaron
and ned stark so once ned married
catelyn
and john aaron married liza this gave
them an even bigger army because now
they joined forces with their father
as well as some of his banners those
forces who were in support of the mad
king were left reeling
and scattered by such victories though
they did their best to rally back
however robert ned and john aaron still
had the momentum
the kingsguard were sent out to recover
the remnants of lord connington's force
and rhaegar targaryen returned from the
south to take command of the new levees
being raised in the crown lands
the partial victory at ashford which led
to robert's march to the riverlands had
left the stormlands open to lord tyrell
the reach lord swept away all resistance
and settled into besieged storm's end
shortly afterward the host was joined by
lord redwine's mighty fleet from the
arbor
completing the siege by land and sea
from dorne
in defense of elio martell ten thousand
spears came over the boneway
and marched to king's landing to bolster
the hosts that rhaegar was raising
those who were there at court during
this time have recounted that the mad
king's behavior was erratic
he was untrusting a vinny save his
kingsguard and then only and perfectly
for he kept sir jaime lannister close at
all hours to serve as a hostage against
his father
now i'm sure that won't blow up right in
his face when rhaegar finally marched up
the king's road to the trident
with him were all but one of the king's
guard who had remained in king's landing
sir barest and the bold sir john a thor
dary
and lewin of dorne lewin martell took
command of the dornish troop sent by his
nephew doran martell
but it is said that he did so only after
threats from the mad king
only the young sir jamie lannister
remained in king's landing
of the famous battle on the trident much
has been written and said
robert and rhaegar's armies clashed at
the crossing that would ever after be
called the ruby ford for the scattered
rubies on rhaegar's armor
the opponents were well matched
rhaegar's forces numbered some forty
thousand
nearly four thousand of them were
knights while the rebels had somewhat
fewer men
but those they had were already battle
tested while much of rhaegar's force was
raw and new
the battle at the ford was fierce and
many lies were lost in the fray
sir jonathord derry was cut down in the
midst of the conflict
as well as lou and martel of dorne
however
the most important death was yet to come
the battle screamed about lord robert
and prince rhaegar both and by the wills
of the gods
or by chance or maybe even by design
they met at the shallows of the ford the
knights fought valiantly upon their
destriers
according to all accounts for despite
his crimes
rhaegar was no coward robert baratheon
was wounded by
rhaegar and the combat yet in the end
baratheon's ferocious strength
and his thirst to avenge the shame
brought upon his stolen betrothed
showed greater while the battle crashed
around them
robert with his warhammer and his great
antlered helm
the targaryen prince armored all in
black on his breastplate was the
three-headed dragon of his house
shining bright with rubies that flash
like fire in the sunlight
the waters of a trident ran red around
the hooves of their horses as they
circled and clashed
again and again until at last a crushing
blow from robert's hammer
stove in the dragon in the chest beneath
it when ned stark had finally come on
the scene
rhaegar lay dead in the stream while men
of both armies scrabbled into swirling
waters for rubies knocked free of his
armor
some of rhaegar supporters began fleeing
from the field
robert's injury stopped him from chasing
them down so he gave that into the hands
of lord eddard stark
sir barest and selmy was also badly
wounded during the battle
but robert wouldn't allow anyone to kill
him instead
he sent his own maester to help the
great knight in such fashion did the
future king win the fierce devotion of
his friends and allies
four very few men were ever so
open-handed and merciful as robert
baratheon
ravens flew and more messengers raced to
spread the word of the victory at ruby
ford
when the news made it to the red keep it
was said the mad king heiress cursed the
dornish
certain that lewin martell had betrayed
rhaegar he
sent his pregnant wife rhaella and his
younger son and new heir viserys away to
dragonstone
but elia was forced to remain in king's
landing with rhaegar's children as a
hostage against dorne
having burned his last hand lord
chelstad alive for bad counsel during
the war
heiress now appointed another to the job
the alchemist resort
a man of low birth with little to
recommend him but flames and trickery
meanwhile sir jamie lannister was left
in charge of the red keeps defenses
the walls were manned by knights and
watchmen awaiting the enemy
when the first army that arrived flew
the lion of casterly rock
with lord tywin at its head king aerys
anxiously ordered the gates to be opened
thinking that at last his old friend and
former hand had come to his rescue
the same as he had done at the defiance
of duskendale however
lord tywin did not come to save the mad
king this time
lord tywin's cause was that of the
realms and he was determined to bring an
end to the reign that madness had
brought low
as soon as he was within the walls of
the city his soldiers assaulted the
defenders of king's landing
and blood ran red in the streets the
lord lannister selected a small group of
his men to race to the red keep to storm
its walls and seek out king aerys so
that justice might be done
the red keep was breached but in the
chaos misfortune
soon fell upon ellia of dorne and her
children rhaenys and aegon
it is tragic that the blood spilled in
war may as readily be innocent
as it is guilty and that those who
ravished and murdered elia martell
escaped justice it is not known who
murdered rhaenys in her bed
or smashed the infant aegon's head
against the wall
some whisper it was done at the mad
king's own command when he learned that
lord lannister had taken up robert's
cause
while others suggest that elia did it
herself for fear of what would happen to
her children
in the hands of her dead husband's
enemies now i think we all know who
really did this
her name elia martell
you raped her you killed her children
elia
martell who gave you the order
who gave you the order say her
name you raped her you murdered her
you killed her children furthermore
the mad king's hand rossart was killed
at a gate after cravenly
attempting to flee the castle and last
of all to die was king aerys himself
at the hand of his remaining kingsguard
knight sir jaime lannister
like his father sir jaime did as he
thought was best for the realm
bringing an end to the mad king since
robert baratheon was still recovering
from his injury
suffered at the ruby ford ned stark was
actually the first one to enter the
throne room after the city fell
ned remembered he saw the mad king
heiress was dead on the floor
drowned in his own blood his dragon
skull stared down from the walls
lannister's men were everywhere sir
jaime wore the white cloak of the
kingsguard
over his golden armor even his sword was
gilded
he was seated on the iron throne high
above his knights
wearing a helm fashioned in the shape of
a lion's head
oh how he glittered and this ended both
the reign of house targaryen
and robert's rebellion the war that
ended nearly 300 years of the
targaryen's reign on the iron throne
and ushered in a new golden era under
house baratheon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you